the 2020 election cycle has already
begun and the superstars that Democratic
Party are now more left-wing than ever
before and they're already trying to
outdo one another on the compassion
scale well the first thing I would do is
restore what's been lost the integrity
and the compassion of this country New
York loves you if you are L or G or B or
T or Q if you are black or white or
brown if you are a Christian a Muslim of
you are Jewish if you're a new immigrant
or an old immigrant New York loves you
and what makes us great is we have no
tolerance for hate in our state CACI he
left off Asians and atheists okay
of course when Cuomo says no tolerance
for hate he really means no tolerance
for conservatives and the positions that
they hold because in Cuomo's
compassionate new york there's also no
tolerance for the inalienable rights of
the unborn you know the life in the womb
that his own church says is sacred I
believe we should pass a constitutional
amendment not just a roe v wade law a
constitutional amendment let's write the
rights of roe v wade into the state
constitution so it can never be changed
I think what's going on here is that
Cornwall like so many on the Left is
really worried he's worried that the
Supreme Court might reverse Roe might
send it all back to the states and he
also has to know that public opinion is
shifting a bit toward the more pro-life
position and by the way if America's
declining fertility rate continues hey
Andy I have a question who's going to
pay all those taxes to support his pet
projects of course with zero regard for
facts Cuomo brags that he has this
economic prosperity thing down
we're the most progressive government in
the United States of America we balanced
budgets we are the most we have the most
socially progressive accomplishments of
any state in the nation and it's not
even close
first big state to pass marriage
equality first state to pass $15 the
highest minimum wage
yeah the Democrat Sambas they actually
panned the audience they're all standing
there applauding standing ovations but
they're unconcerned with the real-world
effects of some of those policies namely
this rise in the minimum wage
John blue stain who owns six restaurants
in New York City told CBS we lost
control of our largest controllable
expense so in order to live with that
and stay in the business here we're
cutting ours well this is the third wage
hike in New York since 2016 so who does
that really help well certainly not the
restaurants not the workers getting the
hours cut and not the patrons a New York
City hospitality Alliance survey of 574
restaurants found that 75% of
full-service restaurants plan to cut
employee hours this year due to that
minimum wage hike but that's not all
47% say they will cut jobs in 2019 and
87% say they're gonna raise menu prices
we went out to dinner last night New
York it was pretty expensive already
well this is the opposite my friends of
compassion and this brings us to the
freshest of congressional freshmen fresh
people what can we say now Alexandria
Kashia Cortez who happily refers to
herself as both a socialist and a
radical now by the way I think it's a
mistake for conservatives not to take
her seriously to brush her off as kind
of a flash in the pan or an upstart
she's as close to a thought leader that
the Democratic Party has today and she
has a massive social media following
she's both charismatic and she's
committed to transforming both our
economic system and our culture first
she aims to create a
socialist economic system with sky-high
marginal tax rates you know you look at
our tax rates back in the 60s and when
you have a progressive tax rate system
your tax rate you know let's say from
zero to $75,000 maybe 10% or 15% etc but
once you get to like the tippy tops on
your 10 millionth dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70% it doesn't mean all 10 million
dollars are taxed at an extremely high
rate but it means that as you climb up
this ladder you should be contributing
more well it doesn't stop there if we
get people to pay their fair share
that's two trillion in 10 years now if
we implement a carbon tax on top of that
so that we can transition and and
financially incentivize people away from
fossil fuels if we implement a carbon
tax that's an additional amount of of a
large amount of revenue that we can have
Trevor Noah's like eyes are glazing over
how does this any of this add up okay it
doesn't but on the cultural side she and
others like her intend to use the
government and their positions of
influence now to mandate campus style
political correctness what do I mean by
that well anyone who dares question this
progressive agenda is not just wrong but
they're downright evil so there's no
room for debate only demonization in a
recent tweet she asserts many have
recognized that Fox News has crossed the
line beyond conservatism into outright
bigotry with their financing a Tucker
Carlson and Laura Ingraham well you see
my friends this isn't your daddy's
liberalism where it was all about love
and peace and live and let live this is
kind of the old-school New England
Puritanism with a radical twist they're
gonna whip up their followers to try to
intimidate and silence anyone who gets
in their way now she's only been on the
job for like six days but she's already
practicing Saul Alinsky's rules for
medicals rule 13 pick the target freeze
it
personalize it and polarize it cut off
the support network and isolate the
target from sympathy go after people and
not institutions people hurt faster than
institutions so rather than debating the
merit of policies these new left-wing
progressive Puritans aim to shame a wall
is racist so people who want a wall are
racist
end of story Paul is an immorality it's
not who we are as a nation it's a wall
between reality and his constituents his
supporters now all of you who are doing
better in the Trump economy you should
know this they plan to take your money
away and redistribute it to you know
wherever their pet causes are and to all
of our libertarian friends who believe
that Trump is the big threat to the free
market because of tariffs and so forth
open your eyes these people including
Nancy Pelosi who is self has moved to
the left they're gonna take it all away
freedom of speech freedom of contract
freedom of religion or conscience you
think I'm exaggerating I'm not because
when you say the wrong thing and Ocasio
cortes world they put you in detention
hall and you never get out remember
they believe that they're right and
you're evil and moderates even seem
petrified of taking on these new
progressives this was former SEC chair
Richard Breeden today on CNBC Alexandra
Ocasio cortes joining the House
Financial Services Committee led by
Maxine Waters what's that going to look
like for the industry well maybe she'll
learn something
are you questioning from some of the
some of her economic ideas that she's
put out there I I've never seen
any historic evidence that 70% tax rates
facilitate GDP growth perhaps you know
will we'll discover something watching
this this morning going is that all you
have Richard that's a really powerful
refutation real strong defense of the
free market in capitalism and
Republicans ought to take the
progressive takeover the Democratic
Party very seriously and offer a strong
counter narrative if you want to know
what it looks like to be a conservative
and perpetually in the fetal position
worried about being branded racist or
evil well look no further than Theresa
May okay didn't work out so well for her
to be on a on her heels now Trump is the
opposite he fights he fights for law and
order he fights for sovereignty he
fights for judges who apply the law and
don't rewrite it and he fights for a
stronger economy so after two years of
President Trump we have higher wages we
have 500,000 new manufacturing jobs we
have the strongest GDP growth and among
all the g7 nations but the progressives
they don't care because if enacting
their green contract with America
requires your standard of living to go
down tough cookies these people are
fanatics and they're running for
president but are you considering
running for president I'm focused on my
job but listen right now our party is
going through a serious debate and
there's still a lot of moderate voices
in the party that did not learn the
lessons of 2016 and are not listening to
what people need in this country so I
want to push this whole party we could
go a lot farther we could be a lot
bolder than what we're doing now see you
ruling it out I've never ruled things
out Oh watch your wallet and what are
the progressives actually learning
themselves moderates aren't learning
what are the progressives learning well
not much Americans are fleeing the most
progressive states in America due to
high costs and high taxes now wonder
they're welcoming illegal immigrants in
New York and California they need the
citizens coming in all the other
citizens are leaving our Americans
really ready to be ruled by the values
and policies of progressives in New York
and California let's hope not
and that's the angle